when there's pressure to fill jobs like
we're saying to them every day we need
more CVS for this job we need more
candidates and they're like oh I
need to get more candidates so they can
skip things so not cutting Corners also
not just hearing what you want to hear
so someone might come across well you
know the bubbly they're bright Etc but
do they really want a career in as an
SDR like do they really know how tough
it's going to be can they really deal
with that rejection why are they doing
this is it because they want to buy a
house or support their parents or are
they just a really competitive person
like really digging deeper into who
these people are as a person not cutting
corners and the qualification and yeah
just not not just hearing what you want
to hear